love is blind shake is teasing a new
romance i think the right people are
going to come into my life and they've
already started to taking to instagram
on thursday the reality star looks happy
in this carousel of selfies seemingly
with a new girlfriend named emily
in two picks they pose in front of
chicago's lake michigan waterfront which
shakes new lady even stealing a kiss
in another photo the couple appears to
be having fun on a date night
then there's this video of the pair
lounging at home
let me see that sweatshirt
only fans
and the slideshow's caption gets a
little cheeky shake writes quote good
things come to those who don't settle
but a crossed out word makes a pointed
implication
mainly that shake doesn't believe in the
adage good things come to those who wait
and it's perhaps a reference to his time
on love is blind i think this could be
exactly what i need this post comes
nearly a year after shake wrapped
filming season two of netflix's hit
series
i think you were on if i may yeah the
wrong show
to say the least the 33 year old proved
to be a polarizing contestant i think
you're all beautiful i'm not attracted
to all of you unfortunately the only one
i'm attracted to is vanessa and it you
know and i wish i wasn't and i wish i
wasn't it's nature baby we're animals
we're animals no you treat animals we're
human beings
that shake during the reunion special
where he came face to face with ex
deepti
i've let shake go a long time ago so it
was good to see him but honestly he's an
acquaintance to me at this point i
thought you know we had this bond but
like hearing him tonight he has no idea
who i am as a person and like he seems
like a stranger to me honestly
it's
unfortunate that we kind of got to this
point you know i think it ended with uh
you i don't want to talk to you again
kind of dramatic ending and i was just
like
i'm like okay all right
days after the reunion sheikh offered a
public apology to dt deepti i am truly
sorry
for some of the things that i said
things that honestly just could have
been left unsaid or could have been said
differently
things that never should have been on
national television meanwhile dt may
have a future with another cast member
kyle abrams the biggest regret is i
i should have
i should have asked deepti to marry me i
i would love that between you too happy
to facilitate after filming you know my
number two person from the pods was kyle
and i've really gravitated towards him
and
he's like really my best friend and no
matter if he let like
resonates into a relationship or not
like i just know that he has my back and
i have his so we have this really close
bond and i'm so thankful for it
deepsea and kyle have been spotted
hanging out together a source tells e.t
the two have quote bonded and become
very close friends
i know that they are very friendly
fellow contestant sal is offering his
insight on the rumored romance
even like some of our cast members uh
some of the cast is asking about that um
i i kind of i just kind of want to stay
away they know what they're doing
i know that they've been hanging out a
lot but i
i couldn't tell you for sure what's
going on
you